i am such a big fan of yours does
everyone do this when they come out here
no are you being serious i was
i mean i can't believe i'm here meeting
you i was what what year was it was
first american idol
2002. all right so 2002 i was doing 70
show
yeah i was doing conan o'brien's talk
show
love conan o'brien and i was backstage
and it was the night it was the night of
uh finale the finale
yes and i thought i mean i don't know i
don't really get into reality tv that
much
me neither if this girl doesn't win this
show
are you there's no nothing against
justin warren he's great
but like you were just crushing it and
then i i
forced conan o'brien to leave his
dressing room
early so i could watch because i know
where it wasn't like we didn't have
phones back then
that showed you tv so i watched it i
remember getting so excited about it and
i just can't believe that you're so
great you deserve all your
it was an actual reality show where you
you know people should actually reality
become stars
and they don't but you did yeah that was
so unexpected and so
nice one time it's funny you know why i
knew you were doing 70s show
other than watching it was we had to do
that was my first time to ever do
up fronts like to know what that is as a
person on tv and they flew us to like
new york
and we were on a plane and ashton
kutcher got on and i was like oh my gosh
are they all getting on here i was so
excited nope just ashton you didn't come
you i was so excited it was like just an
hour on the plane i was like oh my god
is the cass going to get on here right
now from 70 shot by ashley kutcher
that's not so bad
no it wasn't bad i just was very excited
and you didn't show up there nobody else
showed up
and then he kept pranking you the whole
time no i think well i think a lot of
i was young i was 19 or 20 but i think a
lot of other people were drinking on the
plane so i was
and i was you know not able to so hey i
was right kelly's sure
um yeah i did it you know what i was a
cocktail waitress at 18. i did it i
tried a drink and i thought it tasted
like crap
and so i never i never really drank
until yeah this industry
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help